[Musique]
le fait d'être noir un rapport avec la
fuite
pour comprendre ça il faut que vous
compreniez ce qui dans l'histoire de ce
pays a fait une angela davis ou
l'accepter je vais vous demander dans
les minutes qui vont suivre de pensée
noire avec moi d'être noir vous
inquiétez pas une fois cette affaire
terminée je vous laisserai redevenir ce
que vous êtes
je vous laisserai retourner à la
sécurité de ce que vous êtes
je vous demande seulement d'être noir et
de pensées noires pendant les quelques
minutes qu'il va me falloir pour vous
expliquer ce que cela signifie d'être
noir dans ce pays
angela davis être noir en 1978 aux états
unis sassine ça signifie quoi
ça signifie qu qu'on est toujours vide
racisme victimes de l'injustice et je
sais que le président est des états unis
said de nier le fait que le racisme nous
séparer reculé pendant les dernières
années mais le racisme et peut-être même
plus fort aujourd'hui qu'il ya 10 heures
anwar se continuer train 3 5e dom
peut-être même mois maintenant
[Musique]
contact et non seulement les noirs mais
il ya des plutôt qu'un des asiatiques
des indiens des mexicains et aussi la
situation des blanches n'est pas très
bien aujourd'hui et c'est cela je crois
la raison pourquoi on essaie
d'encourager le racisme parce que je
crois que nous sommes dans une situation
maintenant où les bleus blancs et les
noirs et tous les autres sont de couleur
peuvent signifier et ceux qui ont le
pouvoir ne veulent pas à leur encourage
le racisme pour que nous
battions entre nous nous battions entre
nous et ne pouvant pas créer un
mouvement unifié
[Musique]